hi this is pressed a locker in this
video I'm going to teach you a cool math
trick where you can tell whether a
number is divisible by seven just by
using this graph let me explain the
instructions you start out by placing
your finger on the circle that's labeled
yes for the first and leftmost digit of
the number you want to move a number of
black arrows equal to the value of that
first digit before you get to the next
digit of the number you want to move one
green arrow which brings you to another
circle you repeat these steps for each
digit in the number except for the very
last digit where you don't want to move
a green arrow the number will be
divisible by seven if you end up back at
the circle that says yes so let's try an
example let's ask is the number 126
divisible by seven we'll start by
placing our finger on the circle labeled
yes the first digit of the number is one
so we move one black arrow to get to the
next circle before we get to the next
digit of the number we move one green
arrow which brings us to a different
circle now we look at the next digit in
the number which is two we will move two
black arrows to get to the next circle
before we go to the last digit we go one
green arrow to get to another circle
finally we consider the last digit of
six and we move six different circles
and then we're going to end up at a
final circle we are back at the circle
that says yes and therefore this graph
tells us that yes this number 126 is
divisible by seven and you can check on
your calculator that 126 is divisible by
seven so let's try another example let's
consider the number 213 start by placing
your finger at the circle labeled yes
for the first digit two we want to move
two circles
move two black arrows and get two
circles around the circle we then move
one green arrow before we get to the
next digit of one for the digit of one
we move one black arrow and then we need
to move one green arrow in this case the
one green arrow brings us back to the
same spot we finally consider the last
digit of three and we move three circles
three black arrows and that brings us to
this circle so we found out that no 213
is not divisible by seven but actually
this graph can not only tell you whether
a number is divisible by seven it can
actually tell you the remainder if we
label the circles one two three four
five and six we've actually found out
that 213 has a remainder of three when
dividing by seven so this is a really
cool graph you can tell whether a number
is divisible by seven and you can
actually figure out its remainder just
through a series of following black and
green arrows I hope you like this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
which you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can also catch me at
presh tall locker if you like this video
please check out my books I provided
links in the video description thanks
for watching